comme à la dominique saint vincent
antigua saint kitts pour ne citer que
ces pays
sainte-lucie accueilli à son tour
chaleureusement ces blouses blanches
venus de cuba
une délégation composée de 100
infirmières neuf médecins deux
épidémiologistes centrelle soignant au
total qui vont prêter main forte à leurs
collègues sainte luciens dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus vous allez ici
pour nous aider à cette lucide je suis
tellement contente et moi connaissance
le remercier dieu pour votre présence
ici aujourd'hui parce que nous avons
vraiment besoin et des rires nous avons
vraiment besoin de votre assistance
cette équipe ne sera opérationnelle dans
les hôpitaux que dans quinze jours les
cubains doivent d'abord se soumettre à
une quarantaine obligatoires neuf cas
confirmés de coronavirus ont pour le
moment été détecté sur l'île dont cinq
nouveaux cas dimanche le premier
ministre et du coup intervenu à la
télévision pour annoncer des mesures
plus sévères
trop de monde fréquente encore les bars
ou les plages premièrement nous allons
étendre le couvre-feu il était en place
de 23h à 5h du matin à la zone à partir
de lundi il sera en vigueur de huit
heures du soir à 5 heures du matin sa
connerie deuxièmement nous prolongeons
la période de confinement qui devait se
terminer le 5 avril en étant maintenant
jusqu'au 14 avril
un troisième point nous allons suspendre
toutes les licences d'alcool dans le
pays
ainsi toute personne qui continue
d'exploiter un bar ou un restaurant
autre que le service au volant ou à
emporter sera en infraction avec la
police a reçu l'ordre de verbaliser
lourdement et de procéder à des
arrestations si besoin les structures
hospitalières de l'île n'ont pas les
moyens de faire face à un afflux
considérable de patients à sainte lucie
le dicton mieux vaut prévenir que guérir
n'a jamais eu autant de sens aujourd'hui